was that what gave you Dad dick
syndrome I'm not sure what that means is
that is that a term you just coined or
is that something you've been dealing
with your whole life and you just
wanted someone to corroborate because
you're the only one in here who knows
what the you're referring to you're
making it sound like everybody has dad
syndrome and every dude in here is like
I have no [__] idea never seen dad's
so I got no syndrome about it but I
imagine if you saw it a couple times you
might be like well I'm curious let's
hear him out like so uh Urban Dictionary
me what the is Dad syndrome the first
moment when you're a kid that you see
your dad's
dick that you didn't
anticipate so wait do you think there
were times that I did
[Laughter]
anticipate I'm not sure I like this line
of questioning at
[Applause]
all I don't know I got to tell you is
that's the weirdest question we've got I
love that dude I I I don't know how to
answer that question cuz also I have
never seen my dad's so listen as who
said I'm lying you used to we we we
showered together well I mean when I was
like a
child that's something I remember and if
I do my brain probably was like no you
don't um all you need to know is you
were standing there and you weren't
getting
wet well correct me if I'm wrong but I'm
pretty sure he used to tell a story
about when we when we did do that I used
to squint at your junk and try to find
it that wasn't it the story is he said
to me he was I was like you he was like
I want to take a shower I was like okay
he was like but I'm scared to do it by
myself I was like I'm go in there with
and so um he was
[Laughter]
just I was like what are you doing dude
and he was like your penis is bigger
than
mine and by the way and I stand to this
to this day no matter how old the other
person is it's always nice to hear that
you know what I'm saying
like it's a nice compliment you know
it's not a terrible thing to hear out
loud
and so but I was like what he was like
why is your penis bigger than mine and
that's when I told him I was like first
of all stop
squinting yeah but I think that would be
the last time that he yeah I mean I've
I've walked in on him having sex but um
no at that so thank God just a lot of
ass
everybody I'll tell you what's super
funny though is that as soon as you say
it that mental image goes back in your
head you're like no